I mean I hope so complicated feelings
about it mainly because of the
complicated relationship I have with my
parents so
um I think that you know obviously I
know that I've been born into an
incredibly privileged situation and I
have no problem or qualms with accepting
that and the opportunities that have
been afforded to me
um but I think that that's more of uh
you know the class that I was born into
yeah where you know where I went to
school and the connections that I was
able to forge with people as a result of
that there are people in my family I
don't really have relationships with so
the idea that they handed things to me
on a plate is sort of complicated but
whatever I'm just happy and I'm very
grateful
that's that's all I've got to say on the
matter